aber mich regt was ganz anderes auf
bärbel bas bärbel bas heißt die frau die
nach dem willen der spd bundestags
präsidentin werden soll bärbel bas hat
das schon mal jemand gehört den habe ich
mich ja und ich habe schon viel gehört
ja den habe ich noch nie gehört
der bundestagspräsident oder die
bundestagspräsidentin ist ja kein kein
nobody wir sind ja wichtig für die würde
und die ausstrahlung des parlaments und
der politik generell die spd hat sich
dazu entschlossen weil sie halt keine
probierte frau in ihren reihen gefunden
hat hat sie genommen besser als gar
keine und ein mann macht es wieder das
führt aber am kern des themas vorbei das
darf man nicht als geschlechter fragen
diskutieren sondern nach meiner
wahrnehmung ist die spd hier dabei sich
den staat zur beute zu machen denn sie
besetzt schon das amt des
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier der hat schon angekündigt vor
monaten dass er noch mal kandidieren
will im nächsten anfang nächsten jahres
ist die wahl bärbel bas soll die nummer
zwei in der hierarchie der politik in
deutschland werden nämlich die
bundestagspräsidentin und dann wird olaf
scholz nummer drei der bundeskanzler das
sind schon mal die drei führenden
positionen besetzt von einer partei die
bei der bundestagswahl
25,7 prozent geholt hat und wenn man
betrachtet wie viel prozent die spd bei
allen wählern hat auch bei denen die
nicht abgestimmt haben da liegt sie
unter 20 die regel dass ein
bundestagspräsident immer aus der
stärksten fraktion kommt stammt aus der
zeit als die stärkste fraktion noch über
40 prozent hatte das geht mit 25 prozent
nicht mehr es ist jedenfalls völlig
daneben und nur am rande gesagt der
bundesbank präsident jens weidmann tritt
am jahresende zurück da hat die spd noch
mal die chance eine wichtige institution
in ihrem sinne zu besetzen das geht
einfach zu weit die uni entschuldigung
muss ich noch anfügen die union kennt
ist vollkommen mit sich selbst
beschäftigt und die anderen beiden
parteien großen parteien in größeren
parteien führen mit der spd
koalitionsverhandlungen das darf nicht
sein eines der beiden ämter
bundespräsident oder
bundestagspräsidentin müssen
andersfarbig besetzt werden da gibt es
zwei kandidaten die vor allem sofort
eingehen in beiden ämtern das ist ein
gehöriger eckardt von den grünen
und das ist wolfgang bosbach dessen
kaltstellung sage ich jetzt mal so ich
nicht akzeptieren will denn der mann hat
wirklich verdienste um dieses land der
hat berlin zur hauptstadt gemacht er hat
das durchgefochten im bundestag damals
in bonn und er hat den einigungsvertrag
mit aus deutschland ausgehandelt also
die einheit hergestellt und ich kann mir
in beiden ämtern gut vorstellen da muss
es halt mal einen eine überparteiliche
initiative ausgehend von der spd geben
wir verzichten auf ein mann und an amt
und machen ihn von mir aus am liebsten
zum bundespräsident den jetzigen kann
ich nicht mehr sehen der hat viele
kerzen angesteckt und viele ausgeblasen
aber er hat nichts hinterlassen was
irgendwie ewige spuren sind ohne bärbel
werk gebe ich dir absolut recht dahin
kein mensch und ist absurd dass die spd
es nicht schafft jemand anderen dorthin
zu setzen ich finde aber man muss gar
nicht so sehr auf die spd schauen denn
die spd macht macht politik braucht sie
können das umsetzen was andere sich
lassen und genau so wenn wir uns
überlegen dass die grünen und die fdp
dort mit sitzen und ihr sagen okay
stattdessen oder sie können ja aufstehen
sie können er sagen was ist mit frau
gehörigen erkannt was passiert da war
auch die union könnte und die union
sagen wir so nicht aber die beiden
natürlich völlig die zerreißen sich
dabei der frage wer irgendwie vize
präsidentin wird wo man sich fragt mein
gott seit ihr weit unten angekommen dass
sie ihren posten geschacher um die
letzten posten habe die ist in der
opposition gibt aber ich finde der spd
ist der wenig vorzuwerfen das zeigt
erneut dass die truppe um olaf scholz
und um lars klingbeil und viele andere
einfach momentan zumindest politisch am
klügsten verhandelt und am klügsten ihre
macht politik durchsetzt warum macht
politik weil posten bedeutend macht
bedeuten ein dass das sind wie die
schlafwandler die tasten sich durch
einen dunklen raum sie sehen nichts da
sein leerer stuhl da setzen wir uns mal
drauf ja so ist das jetzt in der
deutschen politik die anderen kennen und
dies sehen was sich machen lässt als bei
den grünen kann ich es mir auch
ehrlicherweise gar nicht erklären weil
die in meinen augen eigentlich
mindestens dieses übersteigertes
selbstbewusstsein haben was die
sozialdemokraten auch an den tag legen
da weiß ich es wirklich nicht bei der
union nämlich in absolut recht da ist
einfach das ist der berühmte schlafen
darf ein gerader und ich habe die
befürchtung dass all das was über
erneuerungen gesagt worden ist und über
den biss und über die progressive
zukunft gewandtheit die wir brauchen das
das lippenbekenntnisse sind und das
finde ich das kann eigentlich sein und
ganz unabhängig davon wer ist denn frau
waas ich kannte sie auch nicht weiß ich
alleine aber nur eine assoziation
es gibt bei jim knopf und lukas der
lokomotivführer gibt es eine frau waas
die hat auf der insel und da geht eine
entscheidende rolle ich dachte automat
beste wer ist das denn also ist auf ich
bin ja erleichtert ja auch nicht kann
denn als wir einen jahre kannte die rede
als gesundheitsministerin gehandelt und
ich sage ich habe den namen noch nie
gehört haben musste erst mal googeln wie
die kennst du nicht unterkriegen mich
jetzt sehr erleichtert dass ich nicht
der antike und wissen was ich sagen
wollte ist er ganz kurz am hut haben
dann muss er sie googeln man informiert
sich darüber diese person und was was
sie wieder sehen sie es vom linken
spektrum so ist jetzt nicht gerade die
pragmatikerin ist auch ein signal was
ich nicht auch bedient werden irgendwie
und das anders aber wenn sie das ist ja
irgendwie wieder frauen und er ist mit
der fraktion gewählt der sollte hier
nützt nichts nützen sollte hier
kann ich meine caroline du sitzt hier am
tisch das war eine sehr bewegende worte
über deinen vater kann ich mir
vorstellen auch eine enge bindung nicht
in meinen ja ja aber was ist denn dabei
empfunden als er gesagt hat steht unter
selbst vielleicht werden sollte er
zweierlei im allerersten natürlich stolz
immer dieser warme stolz da einen
überkommt wenn man sowas hört auf der
anderen seite aber auch eine gewisse
wehmut weil man weiß es wird niemals so
eintreten und es genügt nicht es reicht
nicht sich verdient gemacht zu haben
gute leistung gebracht zu haben ich habe
das was da werden es vielleicht auch nie
erfahren jetzt in gänze ob und was
jemals vorgefallen ist aber dass er
nicht in position gekommen ist ja sehr
gut hätte bedienen und spiel minister
zum beispielsweise um das land auch noch
ein stück weit aktiver gestalten zu
können der saftig kite von frau merkel
die sind über jahre gepflegt hatte das
kommentiere ich das kann sein aber
er hat ja schon jetzt ihre kanzler der
herzen
als einige der eintritt ist ja schon mal
aber macht politik von mosbach wie muss
man sich das dann vorstellen auch in
ihrer partei wie wird so geschafft hat
um die posten wie geht das geht das per
telefon trifft man sich da im
hinterzimmer immer noch wie wird das
ausgehandelt also ich anders als bei den
grünen auf jeden fall die das muss ich
ihnen wirklich zugute halten die das ja
offen auf parteitagen ja die darum
kämpfen die dann wirklich
ihren streit auch öffentlich austragen
und dann wirklich um listen kämpfen um
listenplätze das haben wir alles nicht
bei uns es tatsächlich in den berühmten
hinterzimmer nach wie vor ich glaube
nicht dass es langfristig gut geht weil
dafür wir sehen ja wo wir jetzt gelandet
sind wo wird aber rausgekommen sind
hätte ich mir absolut nicht zielführend
aber wir werden sehen was passiert es
gibt ja diesen schönen terminus der
teppichhändler runde wenn es um die
besetzung der ausschussvorsitzenden geht
ich glaube das ist sagt ein journalist
das ist doch mal ein bisschen weiter
denken also über den einen posten haben
jetzt gesprochen der ist entschieden
worden
jetzt geht es ja dann bald auch um die
frage wer wird was im kabinett
als insider was ist da schon was ist das
schon entschieden worden bei den
verstand glaube dass wir uns darauf
einstellen können dass christian lindner
finanzminister wird ich glaube dass die
grünen dann nur eine gegenposition
aufbauen weil sie das klima ministerium
mit vetorecht haben wollen dann müssen
sie ein bisschen die vorlage gehen das
werden sie auch kriegen wenn ich
überzeugt von dann glaube ich tendiere
ich dazu dass
die kanzlerkandidatin der grünen aus
ministerin wird hat ja mal da für sich
geworben dass sich im völkerrecht
auskennt dann nicht ganz so belastbar
wie man dachte aber immerhin und dann
könnte robert habeck super klimaminister
werden was eine sehr anstrengende
geschichte wird dann ist die frage was
da alles noch mit eingepackt wird dieses
ministerium ob das gesamte umwelt mensch
haben damit reinkommt teile des
wirtschaftsministeriums energie und so
weit jedenfalls ein riesen aufgabe er
sowieso der starke mann in dieser truppe
jetzt und dann ich werde mit
gesundheitsminister das interessiert das
ist jetzt wieder ran denn nie wieder los
werden wir in europa eine grüne die fdp
will das ministerium nicht definitiv hat
schon abgesagt habe ich mich erkundigt
und wir brauchen keine angst zu haben
wenn nicht kälter war es wird nicht klar
lauterbach die wären verrückt wenn sie
steht laut basis der eigenen partei
verhasst er war es schon seit vielen
jahren verhasst er hat sich nicht
eingeführt man hat ja dieses gruppenbild
gesehen dass man der neuen fraktion
gemacht war das als er ganz am rand und
er war der einzige mit maske das sagt
alles man ist total isoliert und wenn
der neue kanzler nicht total verrückt
ist dann nimmt er ihn schon deshalb
nicht mit rein weil er natürlich ständig
der mann richard ständig nach hinten
immer wieder zurück zur pandemie er
braucht aber gesundheitsminister oder
ministern die nach vorne geht ich glaube
die grünen machen das weil die drei
männer posten in diesem kabinett für die
spd sind schnell vergeben das ist
hubertus heil für arbeit und soziales
das ist vielleicht der innenminister von
niedersachsen auf dem
innenministerposten und der mit der
früheren frau von jörg schröder
zusammenlebt und das könnte auch lars
klingbeil für verteidiger spreche ich
drei niedersachsen niemals die union hat
nur mit mit nordrhein westfalen
[Musik]